welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with Mary Ann
on Netflix opening a new chapter on
television horror I thought I'd go
through the show and break down
everything that you need to know about
it and it's ending throughout this video
I'll be discussing the major plot
elements of the French horror show
as well as what we can take from the
final scenes of the limited series there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to watch it yet
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for quick in this
video now let's get into my breakdown of
Mary Ann we follow Emma a successful
horror writer who has decided that it's
time to close the book on her biggest
creation Maryanne Emma's book centers
around the character Lizzie Locke who is
haunted by the demonic force Maryanne
and due to their gripping narrative the
stories have went on to become big
business however Emma feels that she's
finished with the character and the show
opens with their pretty much announcing
that her latest entry will be the last
this comes much to the behest of her
fans most notably her childhood friend
Carol who claims that her mother is in
fact possessed by Mary Ann and that if
she doesn't continue writing then bad
things will happen to her and her family
this seems to hold a lot of weight after
Carol commits suicide and Emma journeys
back to her childhood home to discover
that Carol's mother is indeed possessed
by the witch she demands that emma
continues her stories and after her
parents go missing emma begins to write
once more we learned throughout the show
that the stories of Lizzie Locke have
been somewhat autobiographical and that
Mary Ann has haunted Emma her entire
life we discovered that 15 years prior
Emma and her childhood friends known as
the shipwreck kids at Simon Mary Ann and
now with the creature on the loose
Emma's news stories seem to be coming to
life Emma makes several advances to
Sebby her childhood crush throughout the
season though he rejects them due to
loving his heavily pregnant wife and her
child he seemingly comes around to it
and the two do sleep together which
plays into the end which I'll get into
later but you have to be aware that Mary
Ann is manipulative and plays on the
emotion of the cast throughout making
them carry out its will it's a truly
gripping show that is laced with
tons of terrifying moments that have
genuine scares to them every character
is perfectly played by the actor in the
role most notably Morel hopes Naya who
completely embodies the demonic force
every time she appears on screen you
genuinely scared over what she could do
next and she quickly cements herself as
one of Horrors best new icons within the
first episode Marianne is a show that
steeped in atmosphere and darkness from
beginning to end it's unnerving and
feels like a timely horror rather than
something that was filmed this year
every captures the feeling of dread from
films like The Shining and is truly
captivating throughout the show itself
is built around a nursery rhyme in both
structure and plot throughout the season
we hear the tale of Marianne who was
born on a Tuesday happy on a Wednesday
married on a Thursday which on a Friday
caught on a Saturday judged on a Sunday
executed on Monday and buried on a
Tuesday this instantly brought up
visions for me of the batman films
solomon grundy but it's also how the
show operates there are eight days in
the nursery rhyme the season takes place
over a episodes and the show itself
takes place over eight days the finale
is called Tuesday and similar to the
nursery rhyme it's also the end of Mary
Ann the group's seemingly discover Mary
Ann's grave and using a piece of
parchment that was there during her pact
with the devil she's finally destroyed
it comes at a heavy cost though with the
priest sacrificing himself and Emma has
to travel to a spirit like dimension in
order to stop the creatures possession
the day is seemingly won now and it
looks like emma is finally free of the
torment of the character after waking up
in the hospital
however Camille Emma's assistant is
seemingly mute over the whole ordeal and
Emma vows to visit her father often
having previously ignored her home in
the end as she travels home with Camille
we begin to see her vomit which is later
revealed to be caused by pregnancy Emma
seemingly slept with Sebby during the
season however looking back at it things
may not have been what they seemed we
know that Mary Ann was famous for never
coming away empty-handed
and it seems that in the end she did get
something a child now there's a lot of
evidence that Sebby was not in fact
savvy but rather a manifestation of the
character by Maryann firstly Sebby
uncharacteristically stated a lot of
distaste for his wife and seemed more
than open to sleeping with Emma which
previously he'd been completely against
he's also completely gone in the morning
and in their final farewell he doesn't
even know what Emma is talking about
when she brings up sleeping with him and
he flat-out denies everything
he seems angered that Emma is once more
trying to ruin his family's life and I
think it's pretty safe to say that we
don't need to take him on the Jeremy
Kyle show to do a lie detector test
he is not the father Camille finally
breaks his silence and hints that she
knows what's been going on even going to
get a pregnancy test instinctively in
the final narration we learn that Lizzie
kept a piece of dogness with her and she
will warm it up within her in her lap
she will transform it this highlights
that Marianne isn't as gone as we were
led to believe and in the end it could
be Emma's trial that carries on her
legacy
Emma's creation in the book was easy
enough to get rid of but her creation as
a person well that's completely
different I can imagine that this will
probably be the major conflict that
springs forth in a second season as
Marianne died due to the work and
storyline dying out she had to find a
new method in order to live on and
making Emma pregnant is as good as it
gets in terms of a contingency plan it
ends the series on a bittersweet note
and lets us know that though we will be
getting more of the bench worthy horror
things aren't going to be easy for Emma
but what did I think of Maryanne overall
well I thought that the show was
incredible and it truly is one of the
best horror television series that have
watched probably since the haunting of
Hell House
this is incredibly creepy and all of the
performances are spellbinding the season
is about returning to face your past and
things that you may have tried to bury
and as far as skeletons in the closet go
Mary Ann certainly is one of the most
terrifying I did watch the show with
both dubs and Serbs and I have to say
that if you are planning on checking
this out then it may be best going with
the native language as there are a lot
of elements to the performance that work
bare as opposed to the overlay in the
end though whichever version you watch
the show of you're in for a real treat
and Marianne is spellbinding throughout
I really wish I chosen to watch this
over wasting
my time with the island so if you missed
this last weekend then there's never
been a better time to check it out
Maryann is great and that's why I get an
8.5 out of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this show and if you enjoyed it or
not let me know your thoughts on the
ending and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my full breakdown of every time that
penny wise made an appearance in the
background of a scene in it chapter one
and two we went over the movie with a
fine-tooth comb and there's definitely
some in there that will surprise you so
make sure you check that out after this
if you want something to watch if you
want to come talk to me about movies TV
shows games and comic books and you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this well - just one let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on Mary
Ann in the comments section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from then to have a good
surprise it's the best of luck that
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]